Vaccines,
um,
have a variety of guises.
So some of the Audi vaccines,
well known as attenuated vaccines,
that's is the infectious organism had
been changed such it could still
replicate and even body but not cause
disease.
And this is what happened with the first
vaccine.
Um,
I couldn't fight by Jenna using cow pox
as a means of preventing smallpox and a
cow pox,
uh,
had sufficient similarity to smallpox.
It could elicit,
induce an immune response,
which was protective against smallpox.
So that was a whole,
uh,
live virus which was used to prevent
smallpox later on,
people using what's known as killed
vaccines.
So influencer is a good example where
influenza is grown up in eggs or tissue
culture.
It's then killed and then administered
as a killed virus to the individual via
hypodermic needle.
And those proteins are seen as being
foreign by the immune system.
They are an infectious disease.
They don't belong to the body and
therefore an immune responses mounted.
More recently people have been able to
identify specific proteins from an
infectious organism.
A Nice example is the hepatitis B
vaccine where the surface protein,
a isolated from the virus via genetic
engineering and just that single protein
is grown up purified and then used as a
vaccine and just the immune response to
that single protein is able to prevent
the individual from becoming infected by
the virus.
So there's numbers of ways that one can
generate a vaccine,
tremendous amount of change over the
last 20 years.
Part of this has been enabled by the,
uh,
molecular biology revolution coming out
of the seventies and eighties,
which allowed us to clone and express
proteins from various infectious
diseases,
uh,
particularly viruses,
bacteria,
fungi.
And being able to work with those
proteins has enabled us to get a better
understanding as to how those infectious
organisms,
uh,
infect individuals,
how they evade the immune system.
And specifically it's allowed us to find
Achilles heels for the various bugs,
whether it'd be for antibiotics,
targeting various proteins and bacteria
to prevent them from replicating or
antiviral trucks where we can inhibit a
viral to prevent the virus from
replicating in a human cell.
The genetics have been very important
for us to understand how to make better
vaccines against some of these
infectious organisms.
And really just studying these,
uh,
bugs,
at a very detailed level and their
interaction with the immune system helps
us understand how we could perhaps help
the immune system do a better job at
preventing infection.
So generating vaccines that don't
utilize the whole,
uh,
infectious organism,
just using parts of it,
uh,
and by generating what we would call a
neutralizing immune response,
whether it be antibodies which bind
specifically to,
uh,
proteins on the bug and effectively take
it out of circulation and prevent the
person from being infected.
The science around infectious diseases
has been really quite key to our
understanding,
uh,
and give us some really key insights
into,
uh,
the immune system.
And based on our increased understanding
of the immune system over the last 20
odd years has enabled us to discern how
we could perhaps,
um,
use the immune system to manage disease
in a way that people probably hadn't
thought about.
Um,
only a few years ago.
Being so interested in vaccines and
seeing how much,
uh,
you know,
potential they hold for us.
I think we have to see Jenna who
effectively invented vaccination as
being,
uh,
a tremendous,
um,
stalwart and inventor in the area.
So he probably is my number one public
health hero,
but then we have to go to people like
saul can,
saving who invented the polio vaccines,
and,
uh,
you can go on and on,
but I think it's probably because the
vaccines have had such a major impact in
improving public health throughout the
whole world.
Uh,
that one has to look to the
vaccinologist as,
uh,
being public health heroes.
Yeah.